while keeping a check on the amount of
flow sent through it each edge so hereby
flow I just mean a directed path from a
source to a sink to the corresponding
sink so we say the multi commodity flow
rate is our if the the amount of flow
sent between each sourcing pair is at
least R and the total flow through it
through and edges upper bounded by its
capacity so the Maxima the optimal R is
the multi commodity flow rate and for
the rest of the talk we will denote this
rate by MC F of G so now think of this
think of you have a network and flows
and what a multi what we are saying is
like we are transferring information or
around the network through flows of
packets and what this does is that
whenever you receive a packet a multi
commodity flow rate is such that it will
just send it in some other direction so
what it doesn't do is like it doesn't do
the encodings on the intermediate nodes
and so the question is that can we get
better information rate that is better
information transfer rate between the
sourcing pairs if the commodities are
bits and we can use bit tricks on them
so okay formally we this leads to the
field of network coding which was
introduced in 2000 by elsewhere at all
okay so now think of each each source
wants to send a message
M I to its corresponding the sink and on
each edge we have some alphabet
associated with it and that whatever is
sent on that edge is a function of the
entire message set to that alphabets
alphabet set so how you can compute this
alphabet for an edge is is a function of
the incoming elf function of the
alphabets on the incoming edges okay
look at this example so for this note
there was x1 coming where x1 is a bit 0
or 1 there was x1 coming coming in to
this note and the Dell four bits on the
outgoing edges should be a function of
these incoming edges so here the the
this node sends x1 2 to this edge and x1
to this edge now for this node as x1 and
x2 are coming it can do any function on
these to do these two bits and for
example in this example you send x1 or
x2 and so the whereas in flows you would
you when you think of flows of bits you
can only send x1 or x2 on this edge and
the capacity constraint is defined as
this that the entropy of this edge of
the alphabet on this edge is upper
bounded by its capacity where the intro
with the randomness is from the uniform
distribution over the message set m okay
so for example the x ones are x2 the
entropy of this bit is 1 and if the
capacity of this edge is 1 it is upper
bound this this is a valid coding scheme
so the entire encoding should be such
that the sink should be able to decode
its corresponding message so for example
in this in this graph this is a sink t1
so this this node should be able to
decode x1 from the incoming information
this which is x1 or x2 and x2 so what is
the network coding rate so right now we
are talking about bits whereas multi
commodity flow can be fractional and so
we want some similar notion in terms of
network coding rate so network coding
rate is defined as the limit of this
quantity where you multiply all the
capacities by B and then check the
information sent by
information sent but exchanged between
each sourcing pair and divide that by B
and take the limit of this quantity so
for example let's look at this graph so
we want to calculate the network coding
rate of this graph so when all the
capacities of one then this edge is is
this edge has capacity 1 then this
becomes a bottleneck for sending like
one bit of information for both sourcing
pairs so what we do is we multiply all
of them by 2 then we can send one bit of
information between each sourcing pair
and the network coding rate becomes 1/2
so basically you take the limit okay so
the question is because this is a limit
can we even compute this quantity
we don't know whether this network
coding rate is computable and so one
approach can be we know what the so when
we look at the multi commodity flow rate
the optimal multi commodity flow rate
can just be found by solving a linear
program so that that is definitely
computable so we look at this quantity
what is the gap for this graph G that is
the ratio of network coding rate divided
by M CF rate so the question is is there
a graph with gap which is greater than 1
any questions
yes we'll get to there that's Bob yeah
we'll get that's a example only for
directed graphs though
yeah so the gap is greater than 1/4 for
directed graphs so the example is this
butterfly Network so the there's a soul
there's a source here and it wants to
send send information to this sink so
there is only one path that goes the one
path from the source to the sink and
similarly the same thing is true for
this sourcing pair also so if the all ok
before that all the edges are have
capacities one so this edge becomes a
bottleneck for sending flows sending
simultaneous flows for both sourcing
pairs so the multi commodity flow rate
is half in this city but using the same
scheme as the network coding scheme as
defined previously we can send one bit
of information between each sourcing
pair so basically you send X 1 or X 2
here and using X 1 or X 2 and X 1 T 2
can decode X 2 so also this this gap can
be amplified as order size of G by
basically using this example and
answering it repeatedly ok so the
question is what about undirected graphs
so before we talk about exact Network
coding rates for undirected graphs let's
look at the let's try to lower bound or
upper bound the network coding rate the
gap between network coding and multi
commodity flow so for this we look at
this quantity called sparsity so you
take a graph and you take a set you
sparsity of this set set u of vertices
is defined as follows you look at the
edges crossing the edges from you
through V minus U and this party of this
set u is the capacity across this set
so across this cut divided by the total
number of sourcing pairs this this these
I just thought so so for example if so
the capacity is basically the sum of the
edges capacities of the edges so say
it's this the capacity is 10 and the
number of sourcing pair cuts is two then
this pasty of this graph is five of the
satisfies and the sparsity of the graph
is defined as the minimum over all use
this party of set u so now
multi commodity flow rate is a lower
bound for network coding because when
you increase the capacity is it's
basically you are and in you will get an
integer integral solution and that is
you can get the same rate as for network
coding rate whereas this party of the
graph is an upper bound on network
coding rate this this just follows from
information theoretic upper bound that
all these edges should contain the
information about the messages that are
messages that these sourcing pairs want
to send so for undirected graphs late in
row proved in 1999 that the multi
commodity flow rate is also lower
bounded by sparsity of the graph divided
by order log of the size of G so what
this gives us is that the some multi
commodity flow rate is less than equal
to network coding rate of G and is also
greater than equal to network coding
rate divided by order log of the size of
the graph so the maximum gap can be
order log of the size of the graph
whereas in directed graphs it was order
size of the graph so what's the
conjecture the conjecture is that liyan
Lee in 2004 for conjecture that multi
commodity flow rate is equal to network
coding rate for all undirected graphs
that is coding gives no advantage
so - let's briefly look at the example
that for which directed graph give a gap
so when you make these edges undirected
so what happens is that you can send
some flows on the backward in the
reverse direction and thinking of these
all these directed edges carrying 1/2
units of flow then you can send one unit
of flow between each sourcing pair so
basically this this graph does not give
us anything okay is the definition says
that if you flip source and sink for a
particular pair the capacity is
unchanged if I decide that t2 wants to
send messages to s2 would it be the same
as a Festivus entity to say nothing that
changes certainly might equality
I mean yeah can I take a protocol for
one convert written protocol for the
other I mean it's not clear to me how
you need to have some notion of what are
incoming
what is incoming information or what's
kept going yeah yeah I'm not sure
okay so there are there is a there are a
lot of papers that produce that produce
techniques for lower bounding and upper
bounding these network coding rates okay
one interesting example is this for
which so this is basically a k3 to graph
and each sourcing pair is at a distance
of two from each other and with with a
bit of thinking you can figure out that
this Parsa T of this graph is one
whereas the multi commodity flow rate is
three by four and so this was yeah this
was an interesting like small example
for which there was like they they knew
that there's a gap between sparsity and
multi commodity flow rate and wanted to
see what is the network coding rate for
this so finally I think in this and this
paper they prove that the network coding
rate is also upper bounded by three by
four using some entropy calculus on this
on for this graph okay so I reside we
don't prove or disprove the conjecture
but we say that either the conjecture is
true or it is completely completely
false what I mean by this is that so a
theorem main theorem states that given a
graph G that achieves a gap of 1 plus
epsilon between the multi commodity flow
rate and network coding rate we can
construct an infinite family of graphs G
G tilde that achieve a gap of order log
size of G tilde to the C for some
constant C that depends on the original
graph G okay
so okay so the main idea is to amplify
the gap and for that we we construct a
graph tensor that as we use a graph
tensor as a building block that allows
us to do the following that given two
graphs g1 and g2 with gaps 1 plus
epsilon 1 and 1 plus epsilon 2
respectively we construct a new graph G
with gap or as the product of the
previous gaps while keeping a check on
the size of the graph and we apply this
construction repeatedly on the starting
graph with the gap to get a result so
let's dive into the graph tensor
construction so so these are these two
graphs G 2 and G 1 that have gap ok
these graphs don't have gap but let's
say just to illustrate the construction
the G 1 has an epsilon plus epsilon 1
gap and G 2 has a 1 plus epsilon 1 the
two gap so we replace each edge of G 1
by a sourcing pair of G 2 what I mean by
this is that we we connect a source to
one side of the say of the we we becomes
yeah we construct a we construct the
source we connect the source to once
while the one side of the edge and the
sink to the other side of the edge and
and we do this for all the edges of G 1
so basically our graph looks like this
and then we keep the source sync pairs
of G 1 so these these these are not the
sourcing pairs in the file in our final
graph tensor G and the edges of G 2 by
that what I mean is that it's basically
like this point is joined with this
point and this point is joined with this
point and so on ok so what why are we
doing this sorry
yeah when you release the nips buy a
copy of the of g2 for that age which
sources yeah so it so we actually pick
we look at the network coding solution
for this graph and we replace the like
in the network coding solution you will
be using that edge in some direction and
then we replace the start of the
direction with the source and the sink
and yeah you need to sync pair to use
yeah will yeah so we will get this so
it's like so for this copy of g1 we
replace the same sourcing pair for each
but then we have to do something more
so what's why why are we doing this so
so the so when we are replacing an edge
of g1 the effective capacity seen by g1
under network coding rate would be
greater than that seen under flows so
basically the effective capacity lets
you have g2 under network coding rate
you get you can send something some bit
some amount of information between
sourcing pairs and that is greater under
net recording so basically the effective
capacity is seen by G 1 for this tensor
product is more so as information
transport grows linearly with capacity
the gaps should multiply but the but
there is a gap for g2 only when also
sync pair send the flow simultaneously
so so for this we have multiple copies
of G 1 and each sourcing pair in a copy
of g2 replaces an inch in a different
copy of g1 ok so basically for the first
copy of g1 the first sourcing pairs of
copies of g2 replace their its edges and
for the second copy of g1 the second
sourcing pairs of this same copies of g2
replaced those edges and then we want to
say that if you are simultaneously
sending flows for all these sourcing
pairs you should see effect your
effective capacity under Network coding
should increase but ok but this is not
enough because so to prove that the the
gaps multiplied we can say that we can
say that the network coding rates
multiply but multi commodity flow rates
don't behave as we want to because
because we create these paths small
paths to reach these things which which
caused a problem and might increase the
multi commodity flow rate to be too much
so for that we our final construction is
based on high girth bipartite graphs
which I won't go into
so the main theorem is that you start
with the graph G 0 with gap 1 plus
Epsilon
and you create another graph G prime of
size and to the C square and the gap 1
plus epsilon square where C depends on
the diameter of the graph G yeah this is
not important enough okay so for
iteration G basically the iterative
tensor is that you take this tensor that
we define partially in the previous
slides and do the tensor product with
the last with itself and you find when
you applied theorem 2 you get that the
gap grows as this and the size grows us
n to the C to the 2 to the J which gives
you that the gap closers order log size
of G to the c1 where C 1 is a constant
less than 1 any questions
can you use it also to get an algorithm
for estimating this
you are doing a tensor with some fixed
gadget and both to the cap amplifies oh
yeah when you get my general a weak
approximation to the tensor thing and
then it's a little strong approximation
yeah might be a computable approximation
of it
maybe it might make sense in directed
graphs so maybe you can talk so what are
the open problems we still don't know if
the Lee and Lee conjecture is true so so
is it 2 4 so the simpler may be a
simpler question can be is it 2 for
linear codes where linear codes is that
all the Rhian codings at a node is a
linear function of whatever is incoming
on the edges and related a directed
graphs like computing the optimal
network coding wait for even for a
cyclic directed graphs is we don't know
how to compute this network coding rate
even if can you even go to epsilon close
to this optimal coding rate so this
question of computing the network coding
rate is also related to this question of
entropic region which I would like this
is also an open problem and it's a nice
open problem so you so lily forget about
everything about network coding now so
now you have joint distribution on n
variables you define an entropic vector
as follows it is a 2 to the N minus 1
dimensional vector whose indices are
indexed by subsets of a set N and the S
coordinate where s is the subset holes
entropy of xi1 xi2 X I will s is this
set so for example for n is equal to 2
this this this entropic vector is just
into P of X 1 into P of X 2 and entropy
of X 1 X 2 and now in tropic region is
the set of all such vectors we know that
this entropic region is a cone under
closure and it has it has in it it
should for satisfy inequality such as
entropy of X 1 X 2 is less than equal to
entropy of X 1 plus X 2 that is the last
variable is less than equal to sum of
the first two variables
and so on so the question is that given
a 2 to the N minus 1 dimensional vector
can you decide if it is true epsilon
close to a vector in the entropic region
and yeah even the side ability of this
problem so here the variables x i's are
not coming from any fixed finite set
rather yeah it's this paper I don't
remember completely but I think they are
equivalent that if you solve this you
can compute the network coding rate with
apps close to Epsilon
was it thanks to me going in I think
just for everyone